weil ich in meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen bei einer neuen
adventure map und zwar mit jump zusammen
mit
da bin ich wieder mit dabei bei dem teil
ihrer bei einem anderen teil von der
epic jump map und wir fangen mal mit dem
gleichen prozedere an wie jedes mal
welcome to pay gap version 1.1 enjoy
du musst genießen
ich genieße erwarten wir überhaupt hier
nichts bekannt na gut als radio auf den
schildern steht willkommen diesem app
ist perfekt gemacht für entweder alleine
wenn man keine connections so gar keine
freunde hat
im multiplayer modus also koop action
mit bis zu vier spieler an aber die
spieler ihr können auch das schaf
einfach mitnehmen dass wir beide sind so
fett wie spiele zählen wie viele spieler
die heiß zum wissen beziehen beide für
jeweils zwei blöcke heute haben wir hier
ok starte hier ok steht da place penny
blogs blablabla anlässt kultur ok
coolste wir dürfen ihr wisst schon
bescheid keine blöcke platzieren kann
abbauen und so weiter wie vor in water
please go back to get you want from okay
man darf dann schauen wir mal ins wasser
gefallen dass wir auf die auf die sprung
plattform wo man runter gefallen ist wir
zurückkehren und julia otto break green
red android wohl und ja das heißt
einfach dürfen grüne rote und weiße
wolle abbauen
du bist wenn du sagst kassel huskies
also gast
das sei wie never be sure to be looking
for hinche es also wie soll ich den
wecker gehen um uns diese gar strähnen
zu holen sondern wir wollen die schon
richtig kriegen das drehen das heißt da
will ich sagen immer man in minecraft
roboter damit man sich auch versteht und
dann wollen eigentlich direkt anfangen
oder was erreichbar geraten portal so
damit wir in den links gehen können uns
jetzt genau da wird wir hier schon einen
hohen score erzielen können warte ich
guck am besten einfach weg dann dann
sieht das auch keine ja ja genau dafür
mache ich das ja so ok ich werde ich
natürlich nicht aber ich brauche noch
ein feuerzeug problem dass das letzte
mal auch vergessen zu sagen und wann
planen wir das wieder mal abwechselnd
hoch etc also morgen der nächste partie
und so wir haben das nicht vergessen wir
haben das ja anders sagt ja das gesamte
schon aber schlechte leberwerte heads
der partie sind beim einkauf hier sind
wir noch nicht hin
hier auf dem schild stand startete hier
konkreter hier hier hier hast du damit
er darüber laufen also ja das wusste ich
natürlich und ich hab hier gerade in
kleinen fehler ich habe hier ein schwein
ein schwein war eine echte schweinerei
ich glaube wir sollten hier drüber
gelaufen sein tun haben wir sehr viele
fehler bei mir sehr einfach gar nichts
nur luft sowieso wo ich bin jetzt gerade
bitten so genau genommen
ich würde sagen es euch gefallen hat
wenn ich nicht mehr aufkommen das wäre
richtig bitter man verbindet jetzt zum
server
in den genannten besser so als wir
hätten glaube ich eigentlich über die
liga erneut aber da alles so aus eis ist
das ungeziefer weh dann lade fehler tut
mir leid
red vom bett magic laut abda
da sind mir oder ich würd sagen wir
spielen jetzt einfach mal mit ja ob sich
hinter sprünge hier
wer springt ethisch ja und ich schaffe
das auch noch etwas
ok uk holding sprintelite blum okay wir
dürfen hier anscheinend wieder evident
da stand zwar entscheide aber so wir
dürfen da so rüber springen dabei shift
gedrückt halten damit wir darauf stehen
bleiben aber ist nicht unbedingt
notwendig bist du du schaffst trocken
nur helligkeit darunter geschlagen
lasst mich runter gestalten durch
schieber helfen
ja ich habe alle hört man dass wir auch
unter geschlagen und am 1 ich bin unterm
eis
ich mag ihn nicht unter gestartet ich
bin unter reis hallo ich bin ich bin
unter max nicht merken sehe ich sterbe
ich hab dich nicht unter geschmacklich
unter geschlagen ich werde hier habe ich
nicht ich dich töten egal habe ich echt
nicht
doch wahrscheinlich davon nicht stehen
bleiben aber verdammt was die nicht
stimmen geben haben
ich habe mich auf jeden fall nicht
geschlagen doch ich war hatte nicht
verantwortlich nein weiche nicht wahr
ich nicht was sprint will help you ich
weiß nicht ich ganz schafft den sprung
also ich schaffe dir nicht doch ich
hoffe mein spielzeug gelaufen
ich konnte mir nicht sprinten meine güte
geht ja hier wirklich richtig ruder
lustlos wie wir hier starten
wir spielen hier wirklich jump'n'run
karten und können das nicht mal die
einfachsten sprünge
nein und ich wir sind wir sind bietet
gute sprünge sprinter jumper aber die
karten mögen uns einfach nicht das der
grund ja das ist der absolute kontrolle
ich bin aber auch schon lange nicht mehr
richtig gut gesprungen
also hat lange keine karte mehr gespielt
ich glaube die letzte karte wäre
wirklich die mit dir hier die anderer
der andere teil
warum spielen wir überhaupt den teil
weil wir einfach gesehen haben okay auf
der einen seite die karte sieht richtig
gut gemacht aus und auf anderen seite
hat uns einfach gefreut beide das
dikator dass die letzten folgen bei euch
wirklich richtig gut an kam also da
wirklich noch mal an euch alle
vielen dank und war wirklich richtig
cool was ihr dann die kommentare
geschrieben habt und auch von meiner
seite danke danke danke ich würde am
liebsten alle heiraten wenn das gehen
würde geht allerdings nicht
gomes da hinten gerade unter 30 versuche
die ganze zeit irgendwie herzulaufen wir
schaffen es aber nicht schaffen das
schaffen nur einmal richtig anstrengen
und dann dürfte das eigentlich kein
problem sein
oder ich weiß nicht ich weiß ich nicht
ich bin ja gerade mit tätern die am
spielen aber ich bin mega halbwegs
bestimmt packt er aus ich habe auch
keine schäden
okay ich schaffe auch nicht aber sollte
mein pc und dichter
heute bald alt ich hab vorstand heute
heute der geil war ok weiter ich bin
jetzt bei den gefährlichen sprünge die
so ok dann schaffst du nicht einmal hier
los ist ganz ganz ganz viel ganz ganz
später springen ich hab's geschafft ich
habe schick bleibt dabei ich kann dir
aufmachen jawohl die trainees checkpoint
ich komme ja vorbei flog ihr wir
arbeiten wirklich richtig gut empfehlen
du fährst runter ich mag ja genau
aber damals einfacher eben wie kommt mir
so vor wie die chefin dollar was ja den
rest mache ich soll es direkt
hintereinander hier schon wieder
checkpoint ich finde ja gerade auch an
der karte die ist gar nicht so schwierig
von den sprüngen ich gehe eigentlich
alle noch der uplay korporation okay
dass so eine kiste dass an dem baum soll
ich den baum einfach mal hoch klettern
ich habe ihnen könnten irgendwann auf
gemacht oder nein ich hab dich geschafft
misst dann kommen wieder hoch her
ich probier es nochmal das nicht klappen
im checkpoint doch ne woche aber du
musst probiert um auf dem baum da drüben
einfach drauf zu springen den baum das
dürfte doch kein problem sein wo ich
hab's geschafft
na gut der messegäste schon mal was da
drin ist neid nein hatte das 0 drin ja
nächstes da drin war steht auf dem
schild ignorieren wieder geträumt oder
so steht auf dem schild check behind er
ließ offen ob man kommt hier noch eine
kiste da hier noch eine kiste hier eine
komplette eisen rüstung und eine gas
trainer geil der erste punkt
hey wenn sie ja ich habe komplett
geschafft what better way to the boat
that primera bitte welche mit cat from
here
vielen dank jdm emergency water stick
oder krieg mag ich es runter mit dem
plumpsklo nach unten
warte mal ich guck mal eben vorbei ich
bin ich auch mal im montagsspiel nicht
kann er den bequemen weg auch das buch
david was sind hier in chur an die wand
lastenhefte diego ist in time erste
switch um die us-open seagate flippten
laver andre denn klaus ist after five
seconds and go 12345 und jetzt los so
wie ich glaube wer auf das glaube ich
ihnen zeitspiel und ein
ich nehme die kiste auf war geradeaus
auf dem weg zur arbeit als beschleunigt
nitro an
nein ich weiß nicht ob ich wirklich
kriege ich versuche ich versuche die
versuchstiere punkt und diamanten sache
ich habe den gas trainer endlich sonne
kiste unter dem rechten dings aber egal
die kriegen wir ihn nicht mehr
ich nehme mir mal die rechte kiste mit
uns auf jeden fall erstmal einen ja ich
nehme nimmst du die beide deiner mittels
ich habe die rechte genommen und die
andere ich auch den zwei gas trainerin
ich habe alle rechten ton genommen ich
habe auch alle linken aber das geld ist
wieder zu glaube ich nenne das wir haben
es doch noch geschafft
keine ahnung oder demut
dürfen wir hier über springer was steht
auf dem schild swimmingpools konnte die
fans es keating
wir müssen das hier das ist nur das rats
tradition
man darf über die zäune nicht wählt darf
man nicht weil hier ist und in sticky
dingsbums ja aber da müssen wir jetzt
wieder zur wir warten vielleicht auch
wir warten
nein wir müssen jetzt wieder zurück und
wieder ein nein da kommt ja gerade die
leitung war
da waren wir zu sehr beeilt ja dann
schaffen wir das jetzt aber schnell dir
du schaffst das nie im leben gibt den
helm hier
ich frage mich gerade doch ich habe hier
was ich für ein helm mit auf habe man
gesagt dass jemand hält ja und diamanten
pressen diamanten hohe summe ich bin
völlig ausgerüstet du kannst gar nichts
mehr kommen kannst doch auch das
schwimmen fällt mir dann auf das darf
man ja glaube ich nicht dass ich dich
geschlagen
ich frag mich dass sogar noch immer
schlägt nicht ergab oder contra viermal
wir danken stand und wir sollen unser
profil
ich habe vier autos fertig
die luft oder lola who would put some
bringen hier die tollen zimmermann 3ds
nitro immer wenn ich irgendwo hin
wertvoll nämlich so gut war war er beim
ersten teil so hier wollte ich aber
heute auch schon einmal geträumt aber
dabei dann trotzdem machen
stimmt schon du bist schon wirklich ein
starkes rowling opfer wofür die werden
ja immer wieder nach hinten so geschafft
hier ist ein häuser sind marios hausboot
accepted open
wir müssen darum umlaufen ok schade
dachten experten achte ich auch jetzt
schon auf das geräusch gewartet wann
kommt denn das wir sonst und ich habe es
nicht geschafft
unglaublich in folge springt weiter und
ich bin drin so einbrecher immer nur
hier im einbrechen
ich habe eine tür auf die so komisch
verpackt also ich bin auch drin gehört
die kräfte bei dir auch so verpackt
überhaupt nicht bei dir ist die soko
schnell den kellern oder was ist jetzt
bestimmt auch doch das wort darunter ok
und toll müssen nein nein nicht so wie
ein kaktus ich hasse die teile ich auch
an sprung
ein teil dreisprung nein haben ist ohne
ich hasse dich aber ich habe eine gute
richtung
ich hab das vor dir ich nicht gäbe man
brustpanzer oder soweit ich hab gar
nichts ach ja ich habe noch was übrig
war
deshalb bitte ich schön
ja ich glaube damit einfach so mit gibt
ihm gar nichts ab brauchst du noch
irgendwas noch drei diamanten an
jemanden hast du noch drei diamanten
hosen nein nein habe ich nicht aber ich
alles ist unschuldig
ich habe schon noch keine schuhe ich
will auch keinen schul laden muss man
sagen wohin denn jetzt auch andere seite
da du schaffst das
wohin da nach links da du schießt direkt
daneben und hätte ich auch nicht wenn
ich wäre so ein richtiger fehler gewesen
der wir an den anfangs sprung springt
nein aber verdammt da würde ich mir so
ein titel bei der bekommt tom tailor.com
hat natürlich auch die erfolge schon
gesichert für unglaublich aber der titel
den nehme ich gerne an diese folge werde
ich werde die folgen der anfahren der
epische anfang es muss auf jeden fall
drin sein
verdammt ich bin gegen die genetisch ist
er automatisch und drin
na gut epic sc passau ich weiß nicht auf
den charakter wir hier einfach ein
battle draus machen so jeder schwert
gegen schwert ja oder schwert gegen cups
gegen sand blog ja genau ich hasse kag
zehn sprünge hast dich hätte wenn ich in
städten hat mir klappt das doch nicht
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die
gastrednerin vielleicht bringt mir glück
macht das die spring ist und alle in
ordnung aber nur die kakteen ein sprung
der als noch andauern
nein immer der gleiche spruch okay und
ich würde sagen dass wir das alles in
der nächsten folge weiter sehen dafür
stellt dabei den 15 minuten
dann knallt wirklich schon wieder alter
schwede okay ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen bewertung gelassen oder yoga
gut ist dann wenn ihr wollt
bis zum nächsten mal stürmer und ich
vergessen die nächste folge gibt wenn
wir bei mir bevor die englische
unnötigen frage aufkommen wie wo es die
zweite folge konkreter höher du hast
dich fatah mit dem beschriften genau ok
haut rein und schaut mit v deutsche
grammatik ist ein mittel